hey if you want to get some epic anime
merch that you're not gonna find
anywhere else check out our online store
anime out Broadcom we have Eskin or
praise the Sun Mele Otis feel the wrath
bond love the pain more Eskin or more
Mele Otis and other things too so check
us out link in the description what is
up everybody its Anna Mac here for anime
uproar and today I will be talking about
the end of the old era of light and
darkness and the dawn of a new era in
the seven deadly sins story
I will also be breaking down everything
that has been happening so far in order
to determine what is likely to happen
next
and what these latest developments mean
for the rest of the story by the way I
have been so curious about what will
happen next and how the story might
ultimately end that I actually had a
dream about it just the other day that's
right even my subconscious mind is a
massive weave and in case you're
wondering in my dream Demong guy went on
a break but it was announced that it
will return with a new arc in a few
months and in that arc the sins would
have to journey to the celestial realm
but enough about my dreams let's get to
the good stuff if you enjoy the seven
deadly sins content right here on the
channel please leave a like to let me
know it really does help and if you
happen to be new to anime uproar please
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications you could also hit me up
on Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar
for all the latest seven deadly sins
news and updates
finally this video will of course
contain spoilers for the seven deadly
sins manga we're talking about the
latest developments in the story so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned
so the demon King's latest forum is
finally annihilated by Mele Otis and the
combined attack of all seven deadly sins
this destruction creates a massive
explosion that is felt not only near the
battlefield but much further away as
well including the area where Hawke and
Hawkes mama are currently located a
large chunk of debris flies towards
Elizabeth but meliodas arrives just in
time to rescue her gelda is worried
about what happened to Zell drous amidst
all the chaos but it turns out that mail
arrived just in time and grabbed his
fake little brother
this is interesting because of how
strained that their relationship became
once they all regained their true
memories but I guess my L still feels
some form of Brotherly affection for
Zell drous and that is why he decided to
finally arrive at the battlefield and do
at least something in this arc I
mentioned this in previous videos but
I'm so disappointed with how my l has
been underused in this latest arc the
ester OSA / my Lark was excellent one of
the best in the entire series and Miele
has been built up for a long time as the
strongest Archangel and an incredibly
powerful warrior the second strongest
warrior of the goddess clan second only
to the supreme deity herself but then as
this battle against the demon king has
been gearing up Miele literally bitched
out and said he is too scared to fight
against a demon king like seriously what
meanwhile you had like Deanne fighting
against the demon king and comparing the
ants power to miles power is just
laughable I mean sure I guess mild did
something now but it definitely feels
like NACA bouzouki thought he had too
many characters engaging in this fight
already
and he didn't really need miles so he
just kind of excluded him because it was
convenient for the plot but this
decision might have been convenient to
the plot but it definitely had a
negative effect on our opinion of Miele
as a character perhaps there is a good
reason why miles showed up in this
precise moment but that is something
that I will talk about later on in this
video in the aftermath of the explosion
and the demon Kings destruction most of
the sins are utterly exhausted this is a
side effect of Merlin's spell from the
previous chapter which allowed the sins
to drop power from beyond their limits
in order to break through the demon
Kings barrier but now they are facing
the consequences of draining so much of
their powers so quickly as they live
they're exhausted Vaughn and King have a
friendly back-and-forth about the fact
that King doesn't even know what getting
married really means even though he made
such a big deal earlier about marrying
the N as this is going on
Zell drous asked smelly Otis how he
managed to contain the power of the
attacked he used to destroy the demon
king apparently the attack had enough
power to destroy all of Britannia
but meliodas managed to just defeat the
demon king without causing immense
collateral damage Meli Otis explains
that the magic lake beneath them
absorbs excess magical powers so by
aiming his attack towards the lake a
piece of advice he received from Merlin
he was able to destroy the demon Kings
massive form without destroying
everything else around them and this is
because the excess power was
successfully absorbed by the lake itself
however despite the fact that they
successfully defeated the demon king the
sense soon realized that the ten
commandments are still intact
because he is a divine being even when
the demon king is utterly destroyed and
defeated the Ten Commandments will
remain and in a few decades or maybe
centuries the demon king can use them to
come back nevertheless there is a way to
destroy the commandments once and for
all but it requires melia with us to use
his original power his own demon king
form zelgius is shocked when he sees
this form and he remarks that it makes
meliodas
even stronger than their father Melly
Otis will attempt to use this incredible
strength in order to destroy the Ten
Commandments once and for all and with
that we can assume that he will be able
to defeat the demon king for all time I
mean you never know with the demon king
he is nothing if not persistent but as
things stand right now we can safely
assume that this is it for this
particular father of the Year 2019
candidate celtris asks Mele Otis if he
is sure that he wants to destroy the
commandments since with his current
power he could use them to take their
father's place as the next demon king
when the Otis agrees that he could do
this but he doesn't want to be like
their father and he doesn't want to rule
the underworld through fear zelgius
doesn't want that either he never wanted
to be like his father and if he were to
become the demon king he would rule in a
way that makes the underworld a better
place a place where he could live with
his beloved gelda in peace both brothers
confirmed that they do not want power
that was never what they really wanted
and instead of taking the demon Kings
place and continuing this current era of
light and darkness they decide to end it
and begin an entirely new era no matter
what kind of era this new era will be
Mele Otis vows to never stop fighting
for what they believe is right after an
epic clash of the two demon king powers
those of meliodas and of his father the
ten commandments are final
destroyed it appears that it's all
really over and melio disinvite zelgius
to celebrate with a drink sell just says
that he isn't much for parties and being
around a lot of people but if it's a
drink between the two of them as
brothers he will consider it as long as
Mellie Otis is buying I mean you're one
of the most powerful beings in the world
at this point sell dress I don't think
money should be a big concern for you
but hey those younger brothers sure do
love to have fun at the expense of their
older brothers don't they I am speaking
from experience as an older brother
myself the chapter ends on this happy
note with malleolus and zelgius finally
bonding as brothers and the others
looking on with smiles on their faces
but wait is that King just chilling
inside the aunts cleavage on the final
page when did he manage to get in there
mad respect though clearly this is a man
who understands how marriage works the
next chapter according to some
translations but remember there are like
four translations out there so this
might change is called Pride gluttony
and scars this seems to indicate that
the next chapter will focus on Merlin
and Eska noir and perhaps the scars
refers to the physical consequences that
Eskin or will have to suffer for pushing
himself so far during this battle and
for forcing his body beyond the limits
of the one we might even get some
progression in the relationship between
Merlin and esken or which would be
amazing because I ship them so hard but
beyond the next chapter the big question
is what happens next this chapter and
the final few pages in particular
definitely feel like the epilogue
chapters from the last time that the
demon king was defeated but are these
now real epilogue chapters or is this
just another transition towards a new
part of the story in my opinion the most
important clue about what will happen
next are the comments about the cycle of
light and darkness and the idea that a
new era is about to begin
clearly we are being teased about what
this actually means it has been implied
that big changes are coming and that
there will be consequences for the
destruction of the demon king the
balance that has reigned throughout the
world for millennia has been disrupted
and now we are left wondering what
exactly this means for the future there
are many possibilities
it is possible that now that the
darkness has been completely defeated
the balance has been disrupted this
means that there is nothing stopping the
light the supreme deity from attempting
to seize control of the entire world
this may be the time for her to finally
emerge from the celestial realm and
attempt to subjugate all clans to her
rule and with the demon king out of the
picture the only people who will be able
to stand up to her will be Mellie Otis
and the seven deadly sins
perhaps my Elle showing up when he did
is an indication that something big
related to the goddesses is about to
happen and Myles presence is required
for that very reason but this is just
one possibility the story could also
take a totally different turn now
depending on what this new era will
bring will the destruction of the demon
king and the commandments have some
other unforeseen circumstances on the
world and what about purgatory what is
happening there now that the demon king
has been defeated and of course what
about the underworld aka the demon realm
also why have the mother of chaos and
Hawke been brought back into the story
at this exact point do they also have an
important role to play in these upcoming
chapters we will have to wait to find
out but I'm definitely not assuming that
this apparent end of the demon king is
also the end of the story now when we
consider all the times that we've been
trolled in the past and not when we know
that the supreme deity is still out
there and yet we have practically zero
information on her and her true
intentions let me know what you guys
think assuming that the demon king is
really dead what will happen next what
does it mean when the demon king and
meliodas say that the era of light and
darkness has now ended and what will the
new era bring hit me up down in the
comments below if you enjoyed the 7le
sense videos on this channel please
leave a like to let me know and if
you're new to anime uproar don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell I want to give a big thank you to
all of our anime uproar patrons who
support us and make videos like this one
possible special thanks to our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh baby Rey nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson Kings ell dress fitted ala
beat Anatole Cassatt Sookie DJ Nathaniel
and alpha do and I
can't forget are the one-tier patrons
the ones who stand above all other clans
including in grata a lowland Adam
Merrimack makoto-kun and the world and
you know he's serious because he didn't
say so Waldo if you enjoy our videos and
you feel that they provide value to your
life please consider becoming a patron
even a single dollar will give you
access to our patron exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these amazing people as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see us bass
cowboys
[Music]